as we've learned words and ideas are
violence which brings us to
the american bookseller association a
trade organization that works with
booksellers in the country hence the
name and recently
they sent out what they call their white
box mailing which sounds a little racist
to me frankly
to 750 bookstores one of the the titles
in that package was abigail schreyer's
excellent book called
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters
if you want to hear more about that book
you can check out my interview with
schreier on my youtube
channel but the mere sight of this book
was apparently quite traumatizing to
some of the people
who received it and that led to backlash
and that led to the american bookstore
association
uh releasing one of the most pitiful
embarrassing self-flagellating groveling
apologies
we have yet seen yesterday afternoon
they put this one they put this out on
twitter this is what they said
quote an anti-trans book was included in
our july mailing to members
this is a serious violent incident that
goes against aba's policies values and
everything we believe and support
it is inexcusable we apologize to our
trans members and to the trans community
for this terrible incident and the pain
we caused them we also apologize to the
lgbtqia plus community at large
and to our book selling community
apologies are not enough
we've begun addressing this today and
are committed to engaging in the
critical dialogue needed to inform
concrete steps to address the harm we
caused
personally i'm offended because in their
statement they did not include the
phrase lived experience
and they also didn't include the phrase
do the work
and we know that in these kinds of
statements those two phrases are
required
you know it's an interesting thing
though about the lgbtqia plus community
we're told that they're strong and proud
and brave and stunning
and yet we're also told that they're so
fragile as to be harmed by merely
looking at the cover of a book they
don't like
so which is it is it strong and brave
and proud
or fragile prone to collapsing into
puddles of tears
at the site of a of a book it's kind of
got to be one of the other right
now the next part of the story is so
predictable that you can fill in the
blanks yourself
i'll ask you do you think that the aba
was forgiven for this grave offense
was the apology accepted did the
groveling and self-abasement achieve
whatever end they had in mind of course
not
publishers weekly reports quote
booksellers said the apology
fell short calling out the
organization's use of the passive voice
in the opening sentence
they also demanded greater transparency
about how the
decision to include the book was
initially made and called for
demonstrable steps to restore
trust with trans book workers and
authors
some called on the aba to offer
promotions for trans authors
books at no cost just straight up
extortion
you want our feelings to not be heard
anymore uh just uh give us promotions at
no cost
that'll that'll heal our emotional
wounds
and uh also 500 000 in unmarked bills
okay uh anyway back to the statement
says aba diversity equity and inclusion
committee member
uh louis korea who works as a bookseller
at avid book shops in athens georgia
was first made aware of the issue when
fellow booksellers emailed him
morrissey's tweet korea identifies as a
queer latino and
fat bodied person oh my gosh
identifies as a fat bodied person
well you either have a fat body or you
don't
but what's the point of saying that
you're either a man or you're not right
uh he said he thought the apology was
flawed i'm disappointed with the use of
the passive language at the beginning of
the statement and the shift in blame
they really should have said that we
included this book
korea said um so the apology was not
enough
so what do they do apology is not enough
what do you do now
well you keep apologizing more from
publishers weekly they say in an email
late wednesday aba ceo
allison hill issued an additional
statement to booksellers
she apologized not only for the
promotion of schreier's book
but also for a racist incident last week
in which the organization
featured blackout by um danielle clayton
tiffany d
jackson nick stone angie thompson ashley
woodfolk
and nicola yoon on its indie next next
bestseller list but included in
incorrect cover image
instead of using the actual cover the
aba used a book cover by an author who
hill described as quote
a different black author a right-wing
extremist editor's note here
the right-wing extremist is our very own
candace owens who also wrote a book
called blackout
apparently it's racist to promote
candace owens who you may have noticed
is black um but the apology said
we traumatized and endangered members of
the trans community
we erased black authors conflated black
authors and put the authors in danger
through a forced association we further
marginalize communities that we want to
support hill wrote
she reiterated that the organization
will take steps to address both
instances
in the coming weeks adding that quote
there is nothing that i can say that
will make this right
this should not have happened i want to
apologize for both of these
harms and for the pain that aba caused
but i know
only action matters these were egregious
harmful acts
that caused pain and violence
one negligent irresponsible and racist
the other negligent irresponsible
and transphobic
she then took out a knife and committed
harry carey on the spot
perhaps not literally but figuratively
at least and even if she had done it
literally the la the left still would
not have been satisfied they would have
said that like that form of suicide
isn't painful enough
enough she should have done something
more progressive like throw herself into
a wood chipper
their whole gig the whole point is to be
offended and victimized and traumatized
all the time
always by everything anything you do to
relieve the trauma
will only further it but that won't stop
the gutless
spineless blobfish among us from trying
now as for the book itself you will
notice
that none of the people complaining
about it
have bothered bothered to articulate any
sort of criticism
about the content of the book itself
what is your problem exactly with the
book what
what is what's wrong about it what does
it get wrong they can't say that's
because the book itself is well
researched
balanced almost entirely non-polemical
and it focuses specifically on the
explosion of trans identification among
adolescent girls
who are so often pushed along the path
to full medical transition
without anyone stopping to even consider
why else a young girl might feel
dysphoric
about her body nor do they worry about
any of the long-term effects that they
are consigning her to
in other words the book from a content
perspective is unassailable
it is unassailable factually
scientifically and morally
which is why they assail it in general
terms on an emotional level
based on the title and the cover but the
most interesting and disturbing thing
about this story
is the use of the word violent i think
um aba called the mailing of a book of
the book
a violent incident and they kept using
you know violence
harm pain all these kinds of words
i can see how mailing something might be
violent if you know ted kaczynski is the
guy setting the package
but how can a book be violent
how can words and ideas be violent
i think the answer refers us back to the
opening of the show yesterday when we
talked about the left's intense
obsessive
nearly exclusive focus on the self
specifically on how on how the self
feels about itself according to the
leftist religion
nothing matters so much as that
your self-perception is more important
even than your own physical health
which is why people mutilate their
physical bodies in order to conform to
their self-perception
if there's a if there's a a lack of
correlation if there's a
if there's an incongruity between the
self-perception
the mind the emotions and the physical
body
rather than try to conform the
self-perception to the physical body
they go the other way around
literally chopping pieces off of the
body in order to make it conform with
the self-perception
everything must be enslaved subjugated
by the self's perception of itself
everything is in service to that
perception everything and everyone
must affirm that perception
and the problem is that self-perception
is a fragile fickle
ever-changing thing emotions
change how you feel about yourself
changes how you
see yourself changes which means that
the world's affirmation
must be unyielding and unconditional
this is what's meant by violence this is
how speech and opinions and ideas become
violent they're violent because an
opposing idea
an argument a fact presented might
undermine or cause you to question your
self perception or at the very least it
may fail
to enthusiastically affirm that
perception which is to do it harm
which is violence everything
that matters to a leftist is happening
in the realm of emotions and thoughts
in the ego actual reality is irrelevant
to them and so
when you hurt their feelings or cause
them to think uncomfortable thoughts you
have hurt them in the way that matters
most to them you have committed
violence that's where this is coming
from
which is not to defend it i mean this is
all quite insane
deeply disordered not a way for any
human to live
it's a recipe for confusion and despair
and a life wasted trapped in your own
ego
looking in the mirror smelling your own
farts
but this is the life that a leftist
leads
and it's the life he wishes for you and
especially for your children
to join him in his psychosis
and that is an infide invitation that i
think we should all certainly
decline well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content